and the problem is that women are bailed  out for every bad decision we make yeah  so it's like if we if we sleep around  there's birth control if we if birth  control fails there's abortion child  support and divorce court and out even  alimony I'm like you get money for just  being married to him shut up get a job  and and then  um on top of that if we're bad with our  money like there's there's a lot of  government bailout programs like in the  UK they give you free housing if you're  a single mother if you pay women yeah if  if you pay women to I think men and  women can be equally shitty and they but  women are paid to be bad so of course  we're going to be worse yeah